it is week two of the vax nevada days
raffle
more money more prizes on the line as
the state tries to encourage more of you
to get inoculated against the
coronavirus
hector mahia live this morning at the
southern nevada health district with
what's on
the line tonight hector
well good morning there the health
district here is one of hundreds of
places where you can go and get the
coronavirus vaccine
and everyone who does is automatically
entered into the drawing of cash and
prizes
and it all kicked off last week with a
north las vegas kindergarten teacher
taking home a check for a quarter
million dollars
others won 50 and 25 grand in tuition
prizes for students
after last week's drawing we were
flooded with a lot of phone calls emails
messages
from a lot of people out here worried
that you were not
entered even though you got the vaccine
so we put that question to the governor
this week
everyone who was vaccinated is entered
in the drawing unless you are a
myself zach our kids you know that sort
of thing
spouses but nevada residents who've
gotten the vaccine are entered into it
all right and tonight's drawing happens
up at lake tahoe nevada state park and
here's a look at the prizes this week
there's one fifty thousand dollar cash
prize several smaller prizes along with
fishing licenses
annual park passes and tuition credits
and this is all an effort to boost the
vaccination rate here in southern nevada
where in nevada all of nevada still
fewer than 55 percent of those
ages 12 and up have received at least
one dose of the vaccine
here in our state reporting live hector
mejia 8 news now back to you